In today’s era of streaming and YouTube
where we as consumers have the power to pick
and choose the songs we listen to and curate
our own playlists, the idea of a homemade
mixtape is either quaint or completely alien
depending on how old you are.
Go back just a few decades in the UK though
and you’d find heavy-handed warnings in
almost every cassette tape sleeve telling
you, quite matter of factly, that “Home
Taping Is Killing Music” with the qualifier,
“And it’s illegal”.
This oddly aggressive morality campaign, which
seems to repeat itself any time a new medium
is developed in the entertainment industry
despite these campaigns universally failing
to accomplish anything, was launched in this
case as a direct result of the introduction
of blank cassette tapes.
Specifically, the campaign was launched by
what was then known as the British Phonographic
Industry (henceforth shortened to BPI) on
October 28th, 1981 on behalf of basically
the entire British music industry.
(The BPI is a trade association that represents
nearly every record label and thus nearly
every musician, in the UK.)
While the technology to record or copy music
onto a blank tape had existed for some time
at this point, a cheap, consumer-friendly
version of the technology wasn’t readily
available in the UK- or, at least, it wasn’t
until a man called Alan Sugar came along in
1981.
Sugar, a business magnate strongly linked
to the British technology sector, saw, according
to his autobiography, “a Sharp-brand twin
cassette deck” while travelling through
Tokyo.
The cassette deck, which was being sold in
a store selling professional grade musical
equipment, could copy inserted cassette tapes
onto blank ones, and even record directly
from the radio.
Sugar saw this and realised that a cheaper,
consumer version of such a piece of technology
had the potential to be a huge hit in the
UK if consumers realised that it could be
used to copy their favourite songs from the
radio for the cost of a blank tape, or even
copy their favourite hits directly from another
tape and share them with friends.
The problem was that directly promoting that
the new technology could be used for unauthorized
copying of copyrighted material would be illegal,
which is when he hatched an ingenious idea.
After his company Amstrad had developed a
cheap, consumer-grade version of the technology
he’d seen in Japan, Sugar personally made
sure that the advertising campaign around
its launch in September of 1981 specifically
mentioned that using it to copy copyrighted
material was against the law.
In his own words:
I told Malcolm Miller to take the precaution
of putting an asterisk beside the picture
of the new TS55 twin cassette tower system
with its “tape to tape” logo and at the
bottom of the advert, in large, bold printing,
we stated, “*It is illegal to copy copyrighted
material.
This machine should only be used to copy material
you have generated yourself”…
This was a cheeky tactic.
People would read it and think to themselves,
“Hey, that’s a good idea!
I can use this machine to copy my mate’s
Abba cassette.”
That was the effect the warning had, yet there
was I, keeping within the law, whiter than
white, telling people that the product should
not be used for that purpose…
Thanks to Amstrad’s device and the countless
copycat pieces of technology it inspired,
the British public could now make copies of
the music they owned and, if they wanted to,
copies of music they didn’t own but liked.
This thought infuriated the BPI who quickly
countered its launch with the aforementioned
“Home Taping is Killing Music” morality
campaign.
Why a morality campaign instead of focusing
more on the illegality of it?
Well, because home-taping (and the more modern,
digital age version of it) was, and still
is to some extent, a grey area legally speaking.
You see, the law, which varies a bit from
country to country, doesn’t seem quite able
to make up its mind on whether or not it’s
legal to make copies of music you own for
personal use.
In the UK, for example, a high court decision
was made in 2011 and made law in 2014 that
made it legal to “transfer files from your
own CDs or DVDs onto your MP3 player, your
computer or other devices” a practise that
had apparently been illegal prior to this,
but was seldom enforced due to the music industry
as a whole (mostly) turning a blind eye, outside
of occasionally trying to make it harder to
do so with various encryption algorithms.
This law itself was overturned just a year
later in 2015 due to pressure from the music
industry, once again making the practice illegal
despite the fact that industry analysts and
experts openly acknowledged that there was
no consensus on how such a law could even
be enforced.
Likewise in the United States, while it’s
unlikely that you’d ever be sued for making
copies of music you own for personal use,
it’s the opinion of the RIAA that consumers
have no legal “right” to do so.
Home_taping_is_killing_musicBack to the 1980s-
one of the reasons the BPI framed the “Home
Taping is Killing Music” campaign as a moral
issue more than they did a legal one (though
they did note in the small print on the posters
they released that home taping is illegal)
is because they had no real way of stopping
consumers making copies of tapes.
Even though the BPI had the law, to an extent,
on its side, enforcing it was impossible,
so they had to instead try to appeal to the
morality of consumers…
This didn’t exactly work the way the BPI
planned (shocker) and the campaign resulted
in a huge push-back from both consumers and
musicians, most notably the Dead Kennedys
who released a special version of their EP,
In God We Trust Inc on a tape with one side
intentionally left blank for the explicit
purpose of allowing fans to use it to copy
songs they liked onto it.
The blank side even included a helpful message
for fans that read:
Home taping is killing record industry profits!
We left this side blank so you can help.
Similar, though not as explicit, sentiments
were echoed by other musicians and entities
within the music industry throughout the UK
at the time, much to the chagrin of the BPI.
Chris Wright, the then chairman of the BPI
and the man who first introduced the slogan
for the campaign to the public, especially
disliked how the music industry as a whole
refused to unite on the issue of home taping,
pointing a finger specifically at Island Records
in his autobiography due to the fact they
were, at the time, selling: “a chromium
dioxide cassette which combined a pre-recorded
album by an Island act on one side with the
other side left blank for the consumer to
use and tape whatever else they fancied.”
Because the world is a beautiful place sometimes,
it’s noted that one of the earliest pieces
of media widely introducing the concept of
these tapes to the world was found in the
Nov. 7, 1981 issue of Billboard magazine directly
opposite an article about the launch of the
Home Taping is Killing Music campaign.
While it’s easy to laugh at this, because
it is kind of funny, behind the scenes the
BPI were making headway towards severely limiting
the rights of consumers to create personal
copies of music for private use- most notably
campaigning to introduce legislation that
would levy a tax on all blank media which
would be funneled directly back to the music
industry.
The BPI’s argument was that every blank
tape sold represented a potential lost sale
for musicians.
Since the BPI couldn’t stop people from
doing this, they used the age old corporate
practice of lobbying the government to solve
the problem for them.
However, the British government did not agree
and despite repeated attempts on behalf of
the BPI to introduce a tax or levy on blank
media citing the precedent of similar laws
existing throughout Europe, the government
remained stalwart in its conviction that such
a tax was unnecessary.
As of 2011, the official stance of the UK
government is that:
The Government considers that levies or other
compensation are neither required nor desirable
in the context of a narrow provision that
causes minimal harm.
Levies are an unnecessary and inefficient
tax on consumers.
They are unfair to consumers in that they
are payable regardless of the use to which
a levied device (for example a hard disk)
is put and regardless of whether a user has
already paid for the copies they store on
a device.
Furthermore, particularly in the current economic
climate, it is not right to extract more money
from the pockets of hard pressed consumers.
In any event, in 1988, CBS music attempted
to similarly limit the ability of consumers
to potentially make copies of copyrighted
material by suing the aforementioned Alan
Sugar and his company Amstrad, arguing that
their twin cassette tape players facilitated
illegal behaviour.
In a landmark decision that set the precedent
for ownership of devices that could be used
to circumvent copyright, the House of Lords
came to the ultimate decision that while the
device could be used to illegally copy music,
as it has other, legitimate uses, it was perfectly
legal to own.
The Home Taping is Killing Music campaign
itself largely fizzled out by the late 1980s
and despite literally hundreds of thousands
of pounds being spent by the BPI on it, the
main effect it had was fracturing the music
industry over their opinion on the legality
of making copies of music you owned for personal
and private use.
It also, of course, helped spread the word
that such copying of music was possible with
the new cassette tape technology…
Although the campaign went away and was wholly
ineffective, the sentiment behind it, along
with similar expensive campaigns, has continued
to predictably pop up with the advent of new
technology that places more power in the hands
of consumers to curate and create their own
music and video libraries.
Beyond the more well known of these campaigns
launched by the music and film industries,
a somewhat lesser known one that is definitely
worth a watch if you’re not familiar is
the infamous Don’t Copy That Floppy ad blitz
by the Software Publishers Association.
Predictably, this was completely ineffective,
though did give the world a hilarious time
capsule of an ad we can all continue to enjoy
today.
Amusingly, the oft-mocked logo of the Home
Taping is Killing Music campaign, a skull
and crossbones with the skull being a stylised
representation of a cassette tape, now lives
on as part of the logo for the file-sharing
website the Pirate Bay.